[Musique]
les jardins argenté est un lieu de
conception partagée à l'image du
patrimoine du plateau de saclay on a
essayé d'installer une vraie réflexion
sur la valeur de l'existant et du
patrimoine végétal existant pour en
faire un vrai jardin de quartier un lieu
de convivialité qui rassemble un certain
nombre d'écoles et qui vient relier la
zone suite de la lisière sud à travers
le carré des sciences l'école centrale
vers le bec
grâce à un système un élément un ouvrage
important du jardin qui est une
passerelle qui est-ce qui ont une allure
très fine et légère qui vient
s'installer sur ce socle de jardin pour
venir rejoindre la partie de lutte et
s'ouvrir sur l'iut
ce jardin est un lieu confortable de
convivialité avec une fortune héritée de
plantation il réceptionne en partie les
eaux pluviales de l'école centrale d'où
une topographie assez marquée dans
lequel on vient accueillir aussi un
certain nombre d'éléments de mobilier
pour
donner des espaces des lieux de vie qui
ponctuent la dimension du jardin et qui
en fera un lieu difficile
[Musique]
le projet du jardin d'entrée se
terminera donc fin juillet pour aussi
permettre une ouverture au public en
correspondance avec l'ouverture des
écoles centrales prévues en septembre
[Musique]